It’s a cold autumn night, sometime in the
late 1870s, somewhere in the Western District
of Arkansas.
The West just cannot get Wilder here.
You are on the run from the law, with a sentence
hanging on your neck, issued by none other
than infamous Federal Judge Isaac Parker,
also known as “The hanging Judge”.
He has dispatched his most effective and relentless
enforcer to bring you back to justice.
A lawman so feared and respected that he haunts
criminals in their nightmares.
How would you picture him in your head?
You are probably thinking about your typical
cowboy, complete with Stetson hat, six-shooter
and star-shaped badge, popularised by Hollywood.
Tall like Gary Cooper, strong like John Wayne,
rugged like Clint Eastwood and full of grit
like Jeff Bridges.
You got most of it right, except one detail.
You nemesis is a freed former African-American
slave: Bass Reeves, the first black Deputy
US Marshal to ride for justice west of the
Mississippi River.
Early life
Bass Reeves was born into slavery on the 16th
of July 1838 in Crawford County, Arkansas.
Bass got his first name from his grandfather,
Basse Washington, and his surname from the
Arkansas state legislator William Steele Reeves,
who owned Bass Reeves and his family.
In 1846, his master moved to Grayson County,
Texas where young Bass first worked as a stable
hand and a blacksmith's apprentice, before
becoming a manservant to the son of his master,
George Reeves.
This George Reeves was quite a high-profile
character, being the Speaker of the House
in the Texas legislature and later a Confederate
Colonel during the American Civil War.
Bass did actually follow him everywhere, joining
him in several battles.
Bass himself claimed to have fought at Pea
Ridge in March 1862, Chickamauga in September
1863 and Missionary Ridge, November 1863.
Now, we will see later on how Bass Reeves
achieved some outstanding accomplishments
in his later life.
And yet, the man must have felt the need to
“fluff up” his military record in newspaper
interviews.
According to his great-grandnephew, Federal
Judge Paul Brady, Bass did fight at the Pea
Ridge battle, which by the way was a major
Confederate defeat, but he disputes Bass’
participation in the other battles.
You see, sometime after Pea Ridge, Bass had
a disagreement over a game of cards with Col
Reeves.
Bass terminated his work relationship with
the Colonel with the only available means
he had at that time: a punch in the face.
That was the beginning of Bass Reeves’ legend.
Escape to freedom
With the serious prospect of death by lynching,
Bass fled north to the Indian Territory, modern
day Oklahoma, not far from Pea Ridge.
During this period, he lived with the Cherokee,
Seminole, and Creek Indians, becoming fluent
in the Muskogee language as well as learning
languages spoken by other tribes.
He did not entirely escape from the war, though:
historian Dr Art Burton suggests that Bass
may have become a Unionist sergeant after
joining a unit made up of former slaves and
Native Americans fighting against tribes allied
to the Confederacy.
The Emancipation declaration was issued in
1863, followed at the end of the Civil War
by the ratification of the 13th Amendment
to the US constitution, which definitely abolished
slavery.
Bass was now a free man and was able to settle
in Arkansas, becoming a farmer near Van Buren.
It was here that he met and married his first
wife, Nellie Jennie, from Texas, with whom
he had ten children, five boys and five girls.
Reeves and his family farmed in Van Buren
until 1875.
What was life like for an African American
family in the Southern states at that time?
Not easy, unfortunately.
The early post-war years were promising for
African Americans.
The federal Freedmen’s Bureau ensured that
by 1870 more than 240,000 black pupils were
enrolled in more than 4,000 schools.
Then, the 15th Amendment granted all males
the right to vote, regardless of "race, colour,
or previous condition of servitude."
Within a few years, every Southern state legislature
had African American members, and 11 African
Americans had been elected to the U.S. Congress
by 1875.
Unfortunately, when Federal troops left the
occupied Southern States, former Confederates
returned to power and rescinded many of the
rights gained by African Americans: these
were forbidden to vote, to testify in court
against a European American, to enrol in school,
to travel freely, to disobey an order, or
to leave a job without permission.
In many states, any African American traveling
alone could be arrested or sentenced to forced
labour.
New codes of social segregation came into
being, as European and African Americans were
forced into separate accommodations to an
extent even greater than during slavery.
This harsh social order became infamous as
the "Jim Crow laws", enforced by new vigilante
organizations like the Ku Klux Klan, which
terrorized African Americans and tortured
and killed those who violated the new codes.
Lynching became common place.
The District of Kansas, must have been a dangerous,
precarious World for Bass and family back
then.
However, Reeves had a very valuable talent.
You see, the near-by Indian Territory, was
the favourite hiding place for hundreds of
desperados, bandits on the run from Federal
and local lawmen.
It was an expanse of land so lethal and lawless
that historian Art Burton compared it to Afghanistan
post-insurgency.
"You could just lose your life over your hat,
your horse, your gun, your woman, any damn
thing.”
Well, Bass Reeves was literally at home in
this hell-on-earth.
He knew the territory, he was on friendly
terms with the native tribes and he could
speak their language.
Soon, this talent was recognised, and he was
hired as a guide by the US Marshals stationed
in Van Buren when venturing into the Indian
Territory.
The U.S. Marshals
Those of you who are not watching from the
US may be asking “But who exactly are these
US Marshals they keep talking about?”
The office of US Marshals was created in 1789
by the first ever American Congress, their
function being to support the federal courts
within their judicial districts and to carry
out all lawful orders issued by judges, Congress,
or the President.
In practical terms, this included some pretty
bad-ass and life-threatening activities such
as
Paying expenses to the court clerks
Hiring court janitors
Ensuring witnesses were on time,
or even – oh, the horror!
-
Filling water pitchers for the Judges, Attorneys
and jurors
But their life was not all thrills.
In fact, US Marshals were given the power
to appoint Deputies, who had to carry out
the most mundane and clerical tasks, like
Apprehending murderous fugitives
Escorting prisoners across dangerous territories
Carrying out arrest warrants
Arresting criminals on the spot
Supporting local law enforcement in their
normal duties
I may have gotten those lists in the wrong
order, but my point is: the US Marshals had,
and still have, huge and varied responsibilities
and were often in the front line of the war
against crime in the lawless lands west of
the Mississippi river.
Especially in a period in which they, and
the private detectives from Pinkerton, were
the only law enforcement agencies with a Federal
jurisdiction.
Let’s hear it from Burton again:
“The Indian Territory was where the majority
of deputy U.S. Marshals had been killed in
the line of duty in the history of the Marshals
Service.
You're looking at a little over 200 who have
been killed in the line of duty to this date
right now.
On record, over 130 were killed in the Indian
Territory.
You also had Indian policemen getting killed.
You had town municipal policemen getting killed.
It had to be the greatest battleground between
crime and law in the history of the United
States of America."
Reeves: Deputised
In 1875 former US Congressman Isaac Parker
was appointed federal judge for the Indian
Territory.
Parker became known as “The Hanging Judge”
for his propensity to hand out death sentences
– a harsh man, but apparently that’s what
Western Arkansas and the Indian Territory
needed.
Parker appointed James F. Fagan as U.S. Marshal,
directing him to hire 200 U.S. Marshal Deputies.
Fagan had heard about Reeves, who knew the
Indian Territory and could speak several Indian
languages and decided to deputise him.
It is tempting to celebrate Bass Reeves as
the first African American U.S. Deputy Marshal,
but he was not.
He may have been the first, or maybe even
just one of the first, west of the Mississippi.
Our expert Dr Burton in fact claims that the
presence of black lawmen and soldiers in the
old West has been grossly under-represented
by historians and popular culture alike:
“If we look at the real Western frontier
… you also found blacks who were in law
enforcement across the West, in Montana and
Colorado and New Mexico.
Twenty percent of the military on the Western
frontier were African Americans” For example
“The majority of the federal workers for
the Fort Smith court, Arkansas, in 1878 were
African Americans.”
So why do we celebrate and remember Bass Reeves
today?
Not only because he was one of those who had
overcome barriers imposed by prejudice, by
segregation, and sometimes even by laws which
today would count as a crime against humanity.
Not only that, but because he was simply one
of the damn best US lawmen, ever.
Period.
[TA1] 3000 Arrests and some unlucky hats
And in the role of one of the finest lawmen
ever, Bass Reeves certainly did look the part.
He cut an impressive figure, standing at 6
foot 2, or 188 cm, sporting an epic handlebar
moustache, black Stetson hat and dark polished
boots.
He was an accomplished horseman and marksman,
due to his hunting and military experience,
and life as a blacksmith and farmer had made
him incredibly strong.
But Reeves was not all brawn.
Even though he remained illiterate his whole
life Deputy Reeves had a prodigious memory
so he just learnt by heart the warrants and
court orders as he received them.
He could also be very cunning, preferring
to use guile instead of guns in many occasions,
and had reportedly developed some impressive
detective skills.
His track record speaks for itself.
Over the course of his career as a Deputy
Marshal, from 1875 to 1907, Bass Reeves carried
out 3000 arrests – that’s an average of
94 per year!
He also shot and killed 14 criminals in self-defence,
but was never seriously wounded, despite his
hat being shot in two several times.
But let’s take a closer look at some of
his most famous adventures.
In September 1884 Deputy Reeves was in The
Indian Territory, with arrest warrants for
two horse rustlers, Frank Buck and John Bruner.
Two local men had volunteered to guide him,
but unbeknownst to him these guys were Buck
and Bruner!
While camping for dinner, Reeves noticed Bruner
reaching for his pistol.
The Marshal would not have it.
He quickly grabbed Bruner’s gun and pulled
his own six-shooter.
Behind his back, Buck was getting ready to
shoot.
Quick as a flash, and still holding Bruner’s
weapon, Reeves turned around and shot Buck
dead.
In another case, Reeves had to face the famous
three outlaw brothers, the Brunters.
But this time, it seemed like the criminals
had the upper hand: they ambushed Reeves and
held him at gunpoint, taunting the man who
was already known as the “Indomitable Marshal”.
Fearless as usual, Reeves calmly asked for
the date.
When the brothers asked why, Reeves explained
that their arrest papers needed to be dated.
After all, they were coming with him – dead
or alive.
In a scene worthy of a Hollywood action movie,
the outlaws burst out laughing.
Reeves took advantage of their distraction,
turning away from him the barrel of the closest
gun.
The other two brothers aimed at him, but Reeves
was quicker on the draw and shot them both
dead.
As per the third brother … some accounts
tell us that Reeves took him into custody.
According to others, the remaining Brunter
still had some fight left in him, until Reeves
disarmed him and cracked his skull with his
own gun.
But as I mentioned earlier, Reeves was not
just about fists and bullets, he could be
sly as a fox.
During the pursuit of two outlaws in the Red
River Valley, Reeves and his colleagues thought
the criminals were seeking refuge at their
mother’s cabin.
Approaching old momma’s house on the open
terrain was too dangerous, but Reeves had
a plan: he dirtied up his clothes, ditched
his polished boots for an old pair of shoes
and shot three holes in his hat.
(We like to think that Bass’ hat-maker was
a very rich man at this point of his career
…)
He then walked 28 miles to the cabin and knocked
on the door.
When mum opened the door, Reeves impersonated
an outlaw on the run form the Marshals, thirsty,
hungry and tired.
Of course, the old lady sympathised and took
him in.
Later that night, her naughty boys showed
up and she whistled to them, indicating that
the coast was clear.
As if.
When the other Marshals arrived the morning
after, they found Reeves keeping watch on
the two brothers, still asleep and safely
handcuffed.
Without firing a shot, nor risking anyone’s
life, Reeves had scored a resounding victory,
collecting a $5,000 reward – that’s about
$121,000 in today’s money.
And yet, despite Reeves’ undisputed effectiveness,
some white lawmen still believed a black man
had to be beneath them.
Judge Brady, Reeves’ great-grandnephew,
reports one incident in which a white police
officer threatened to shoot the Marshal with
his gun, guilty of ordering around some white
federal prisoners – in other words, guilty
of doing his job!
Only the intervention of a senior Marshal
could avoid a shootout amongst fellow lawmen.
Legend of the Lone Ranger
Bass Reeves’ fame grew with each arrest,
fuelled by local newspapers in search of heroes
to celebrate.
His reputation as a fearless, indomitable,
incorruptible lawman, eventually became a
deterrent enough to prevent criminals from
escaping justice.
Just listen to this story from the summer
of 1903.
One night, a man called Jerry Mcintosh had
dragged his wife out of bed during a drunken
rage.
He had doused her in oil and set her on fire,
leaving her alive but in critical condition.
McIntosh was quick to leave town, but while
on the run, he had a dream, or rather, a nightmare.
According to the July 16, 1903 edition of
The Daily Ardmorette:
“McIntosh says he dreamed last night that
Deputy Marshall Reeves came upon him in the
brush and when he jumped up to run the deputy
shot and killed him.
When he awoke and realized that it was only
a dream he decided to come to town and give
up immediately…”
Bass Reeves steely dedication to upholding
the law did not hold back from friends or
even family.
He famously arrested the minister that had
baptised him, on charges of selling illegal
liquor.
And even more famously, he went after his
own son, Bennie.
Here is from the Daily Ardmorette again:
“A warrant for the arrest of the younger
Reeves for murdering his wife had been issued
and Marshal Bennett said that perhaps another
deputy had better be sent to serve it.
Old Bass was in the room and quietly said,
“Give me the writ.”
He went out, arrested his son, brought him
into court and saw a jury try him, convict
him, and sentence him to life imprisonment…”
Bennie Reeves was eventually freed from his
life sentence for being a “model prisoner”,
and he reportedly never committed another
crime again.
So far we looked at the highlights of Reeves’
career, but in his tenure as Marshal there
was at least one shadow.
In April 1884, Reeves had in fact been involved
in the death by shooting of his camp cook,
William Leech.
An initial inquest ruled that this had been
an accident and no charges were filed against
Deputy Reeves.
But two years later, a former Confederate
took over the local US Attorney’s office
and the sentence was over-ruled: Bass was
now charged with murder, stripped of his badge
and held in jail for more than three months.
Reeves and others testified that the shooting
was accidental, with his rifle going off while
Reeves was trying to clear a faulty cartridge
from the chamber with a knife.
He was eventually acquitted, but the legal
expenses left him financially ruined, as he
was forced to sell his home.
According to Judge Jim Spears, a member of
the Bass Reeves Legacy Initiative, the charges
against the Deputy Marshal were politically
and racially motivated.
However Reeves' strength of character is shown
by the fact that he decided to continue his
career after his acquittal.
And so, the Lone Marshal rode again, and became
the legend we know of today.
For some time he was believed to be the inspiration
behind the character of the Lone Ranger, a
masked lawman in the old West, first appearing
in a 1930s radio show, then a 1950s TV series,
comics, cartoons and several movies.
Well, I am afraid to say that this myth can
be safely debunked as it was circulated by
none other than our friend Dr Art Burton,
who hinted at this connection without any
proof.
The Lone Ranger was actually inspired by the
myth of Robin Hood and by Tom Mix, a star
of early Western films.
Rather than claiming that Bass inspired some
masked white dude in a lame 2013 movie, shouldn’t
he deserve a proper, well-written, well-produced
and non-straight to video biopic?
Morgan Freeman as the old Reeves narrating
in flashback, Chadwick Boseman as younger
Bass and John Lithgow as ‘Hanging’ Judge
Parker.
Story credit to Whistler!
If producers are watching right now - consider
this a pitch.
End of an era
The Wild West lost much of his wildness in
the early XXth Century, as America fulfilled
its Manifest Destiny and the Pacific Coast
was conquered by settlers.
By 1907, Kansas, Arkansas and Oklahoma had
officially become States within the Union
and the Indian Territory with its ongoing
war against the law was but a memory.
Bass Reeves was now aged 68, time for him
to leave the U.S. Marshals.
But he did not retire yet, preferring to serve
for a further two years as a Police Officer
in the Muskogee police department.
In 1909, the tireless Reeves finally did retire,
due to a kidney condition, called Bright’s
disease.
He died a year later on January 12, 1910,
being remembered in his obituary as a
“universally respected US Deputy Marshal
who was absolutely fearless and had known
no master but duty”.